ماذا أخبرك عما حدث
مساء السبت حسنًا، لقد انتهوا للتو من
حضور حفلة عيد ميلاد ابن أخي التوأم البالغ من العمر 8 سنوات
وقرر الثلاثة
منهم التجول في المبنى الذي
يحبونه والتجول في
الحي عندما  إنهم هناك، لقد
ذهب كل واحد من الأولاد الآخرين
إلى منزل والدتي في عيد الشكر أه
مرتين وكان هشام يزور
برلينجتون منذ حوالي 10 سنوات ولذا فهو
يعرف المجتمع جيدًا جدًا
ولذلك كان يستضيفهم في
كانوا يسيرون على بعد بنايتين تقريبًا من
منزل والدتي وخرج رجل من
المبنى واقترب منهم،
فتقدموا إلى الجانب للسماح له
بمساحة على الرصيف ليمر بهم،
وأخرج مسدسًا دون أن يقول
أي شيء  أطلق عليهم النار هاشم سقط على
الأرض في الحقيقة قال إنه
وجد نفسه فجأة على الأرض طاهين الذي
أصيب بجرح في صدره كان كما تعلم يعاني
من ألم رهيب ويصرخ من الألم
وكانان الذي ظن أن أه أصدقائه
قد قتلوا قد هرب إلى  حاولي
الحصول على مساعدة أم هشام أه قلقة من أن
مطلق النار بقي فوقهم
لفترة قصيرة ثم غادر فظن هشام
أن هذا الرجل سيستمر في
إطلاق النار عليهم وقتلهم ثم اتصل
هاشم بالرقم 911 وجاء AMT
فقط ابنك  كان هو الشخص الذي
اتصل حتى وعرفت
ما يكفي لتكون قادرًا على القيام بذلك وكنت
خائفًا جدًا أيضًا، هل تعتقد
أنك تعرف سبب قيامه بذلك، هل يعتقد
هاشم أنه
يعرف، أعتقد أن هاشم ورفاقه  لقد
تعرض أصدقائي للكثير من المضايقات
في الأشهر الأخيرة، والكثير من
الروايات المسمومة حول هويتهم
كفلسطينيين، ابني وكانان
مواطنان فلسطينيان، وابني أيضًا
مواطن أيرلندي، طاهين هنا كمواطن
فلسطيني  أم، وأنت تعلم أن هام
كمواطن أيرلندي في أيرلندا سيتم
الاعتراف به كشخص
ودعمه في تجربته،
تجربته التاريخية وتجربته الثقافية،
الأيرلنديون داعمون بشكل لا يصدق
للفلسطينيين في
أمريكا وسائل الإعلام الرئيسية وبعض
رفيعي المستوى  المسؤولين الحكوميين أه
طالبوا بأه عمل وحشي حقا
ضد أه الفلسطينيين الفلسطينيين
في غزة ووقفوا أو
وقفوا الآخرين كما تعلم
واحد من كل 200 فلسطيني قتل
يعني ما يعادل من
القتلى في  بال في غزة في أمريكا
حوالي 3 ملايين نسمة نسبة إلى
عدد سكان الولايات المتحدة لذلك أعتقد أنك تعرف
هشام وكنعان وتي ولم أسألهم
عن هذا بالتحديد ولكن في هذا
السياق وهو سام جدًا تجاه أه
الفلسطينيين المسلمين والعرب وفي
حالة ثقافية حالية يتم فيها
الاختلاف بين الناس بسهولة شديدة أه من السهل
الربط بين الأفعال التي
تجرد الفلسطينيين من إنسانيتهم ​​بشكل عام
وبين أفعال من استخدم
بندقيته للتعبير عن رأيه وما زلنا
ننتظر تفاصيل
التحقيق  لقد تأثرت حقًا
بشرطة بيرلينجتون والحكومة الأمريكية، حيث
قاموا بسرعة كبيرة بنقل
الموارد أه للسماح
بالتحقيق في هذه الجريمة باعتبارها جريمة كراهية أه
التحقيق لا يزال مستمرًا وأنا على
ثقة من أنه سيكون أم سنحصل على
معلومات كما  لقد ظهر ذلك ولكن هذا
وقت خطير في أمريكا إذا
كنت مرتبطًا بمجموعة متورطة
في هذه الصراعات، فهناك
الكثير من خطاب الكراهية ضد جميع
الأطراف وفي هذا السياق السام،
يتخذ الناس إجراءات بشأنهم  الخاصة ولها
عواقب وخيمة